Würdest du noch Fleisch essen, wenn du zusehen müsstest, wie das Tier geschlachtet wird?
650'000 Kühe werden pro Jahr im Schlachthaus geschlachtet.
Und nur hundert werden auf einem Hof geschlachtet, so wie auf diesem hier.
Wir Schweizer essen im Laufe unseres Lebens 8 Rinder.
Aber ist jemand von euch schon dabei gewesen, wie aus einem Tier Fleisch wird?
Wenn jemand Fleisch isst, sollte man nicht dazu bereit sein, auch diesen Teil der Geschichte zu sehen?
Möchte ich das wirklich sehen? Nein! Ich möchte das auch nicht sehen.
Aber vielleicht wäre es mal wichtig hinzuschauen.
Mona Vetsch mit dabei
bei einer Hofschlachtung.
Auf nichts vorbereitet,
aber auf alles gefasst.
Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Wir holen die Kühe in den Stall und
gehen mit ihnen zur nächsten Weide.
Okay.
Wir mussten als Kinder
auch immer die Kühe holen.
Ich habe das gehasst, weil ich
damals noch kleiner war als jetzt.
Ich hatte immer Angst vor Kühen,
weil die riesig sind.
V.a. wenn sie etwas aufgeregt sind,
springen sie umher.
Das ist mit ein Grund, weshalb ich
keine talentierte Bauerntochter war.
Sie sind gut erzogen.
Die einen ziehen vorne weg,
die anderen trotten hinterher.
Wie viele hast du denn?
Im Moment sind es 18 Kühe.
Und 18 Kälber.
Das ist der Durchschnitt.
Manchmal sind es 20, manchmal 17.
Du hast Milchkühe?
- Nein, das sind Mutterkühe.
Ah, okay.
- Ja, wir melken nicht.
Ja, okay.
* Entferntes Muhen,
Zwitschern, Zirpen *
Ich werde kurz ...
- Ja, sag es mir.
... den Haspel dort entfernen,
schneide ihn ab und nehme ihn mit.
Dann öffnen wir hier den Zaun.
Wir gehen voran und die Kühe ...
- ... hinter uns her.
Wir hoffen,
dass sie uns nicht wegrennen.
* Lautes Muhen *
Ja, ja, ja.
- So toll. Schau mal!
Ein richtiges Empfangskomitee.
* Lautes Muhen *
Komm! Komm!
(Georg hält eine fast
verloren gegangene heimische Rasse:
Bündner Grauvieh.)
Es ist eine extrem schöne Rasse.
Nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Diese beiden sind
etwas Spezialisten, Elvira auch.
Sie haben es nicht sehr pressant.
Komm, Schöne, komm!
- Wie heisst sie?
Schöne.
- Schöne? Oh ja, du.
Komm, hopp, geh!
(Jede hat einen Namen
und auch einen eigenen Charakter.)
Es gibt Kühe,
die immer nette Kälber haben.
Das ist einfach so.
- Das gibt's?
Maloja ist z.B. eine ganz Nette.
Nicht wahr, Maloja?
Und jedes Jahr
hat sie ganz zahme Kälber.
Schau dir das mal an!
- Diese Bürste mögen sie.
Ja, die ist super.
- Die ist die Nummer 1.
Die kleine Graue da hinten
ist die, die wir ...
... die wir schlachten.
- Ja, genau.
(Sie heisst Tschigulatta,
also Schokolade auf Rätoromanisch.)
Sie wächst einfach nicht?
- Nein, sie ist bald 1 1/2-jährig.
Und sie ist klein. Ja.
Es ist halt so:
Wir wissen von Anfang an,
dass wir alle Stiere schlachten.
Bei den Weibchen
besteht die Möglichkeit,
dass wir eines für uns behalten  -
wenn der Charakter gut ist
oder weil sie sonst gut passen.
Sie ist einfach eine Kleine.
Wir dachten, wir behalten sie.
Jetzt geht sie trotzdem.
Mich berührt es, dass die Kleinen
geschlachtet werden - aus Gründen.
Weisst du, ich meine, wenn ich eine
Kuh wäre, hätte ich schon lange ...
* Sanfte Jazzmusik *
(Ich bin zwar
auf dem Bauernhof aufgewachsen,
aber geschlachtet haben wir
nicht selbst auf dem Hof.)
(Deshalb zeigen mir Georg
und seine Söhne, wie das abläuft.)
Achtung, Men, Achtung, Luzi!
Gut.
Was machst du jetzt damit?
Auf diesen Schragen kommt das Tier,
auf dem Rücken.
Jetzt können wir das öffnen.
* Er spricht leise vor sich hin. *
Da drüben wird es eingefangen.
Der Metzger betäubt es dann
mit dem Bolzenapparat.
Mit der Kette,
die du am Morgen gebracht hast,
ziehen wir es an den Hinterbeinen
auf und fahren bis zum Beton.
Dann kommt
die schwarze Wanne drunter,
und der Metzger kann
mit dem Messer in den Hals stechen.
Dann läuft das Blut heraus
und es ist tot.
Das Tier wird dann
auf dem Schragen fixiert.
Das Blut laden wir um ins Fass
und nehmen es mit.
Dann kommt alles dazu
und wir gehen ins Schlachtlokal.
Ja ... Wenn ich das alles sehe,
wird mir schon etwas schlecht.
Ja?
- Ja, ich kann nichts dafür.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Ich für mich habe bemerkt,
dass töten ziemlich abstrakt ist.
Sobald es knallt ...
Zumindest bei mir ist das so ...
Ich bin konzentriert,
dann ist es ziemlich abstrakt.
Am eindrücklichsten
ist sicher der Moment der Betäubung,
wenn das Tier
die ganze Spannung verliert
und zusammensackt wie ein Sack Mehl.
Wie wenn man einen Stecker zieht.
Ist es eindrücklich
im Sinn von krass?
Ja, es ist wie ...
Es ist ein Phänomen,
das man sonst nicht kennt.
Ja.
- Und ja, das ist krass.
(Georg schlachtet auf dem Hof,
damit er den Tieren
den Transportstress ersparen kann.)
(Das ist die grosse Ausnahme.)
(In der Schweiz werden Jährlich
nur 100 Rinder so geschlachtet
gegenüber 650'000 Rinder und Kälber,
die ins Schlachthaus gehen.)
* Muhen *
(Bei Georg und Claudia
ist sowieso vieles etwas anders.)
Kommt jetzt!
- (Beide) Ja, wir kommen.
(Sie sind zwei Quereinsteiger.)
(Beide haben ursprünglich
in Zürich Kunst studiert.)
Komm!
* Lautes Rascheln *
* Rascheln *
Komm, komm, komm!
* Laute Lockrufe *
(Nach einem Sommer auf der Alp
kamen sie auf den Geschmack,
Landwirtschaft zu betreiben.)
(Lachend) Ui, ui, ui!
- Komm her!
Die kommen so schnell!
* Mona lacht. *
* Glockenbimmeln, Blöken,
Vogelzwitschern *
(Vor fünf Jahren schlugen Claudia
und Georg eine neue Richtung ein.)
(Sie konnten diesen Bio-Hof
in Pastels pachten
mit etwas Ackerbaufläche
und vielen Tieren.)
* Helles Glockenläuten, Blöken *
(Viel Ahnung von Landwirtschaft
hätten sie zuvor nicht gehabt.)
(Georgs Vater ist Arzt, Claudia
kommt aus einer Tierarztfamilie.)
(Zu den Tieren hatte sie
immer eine enge Beziehung.)
* Gläserne Klänge *
Du wolltest nie Tierärztin werden
wie dein Vater?
Nein. Ich muss sagen,
ich sehe auch nicht gerne Blut.
Das ist wirklich nicht so ...
Das hätte ich nicht gemacht.
Das wird beim Schlachten
aber ein Problem, oder?
Nein, ich bin da nicht dabei.
Du darfst dann.
Nein, ich kann das auch nicht gut.
Hast du dir schon überlegt, wenn du
selbst nicht schlachten möchtest,
ob es nicht besser wäre,
gar keine Tiere zu haben?
Auf diesem Hof
ist das wenig sinnvoll.
Hier hat es Wiesen,
auf denen man keine menschliche
Nahrung produzieren könnte.
Man könnte sie nicht nutzen.
- Genau.
Unten machen wir
keine Tiernahrung mehr.
Da haben wir nur noch Hirse,
Linsen, Getreide -
alles menschliche Nahrung.
V.a. oben im Berggebiet
ist es sinnvoll, Tiere zu haben -
für die Entbuschung,
zum Düngen der Weiden.
Um eben die Tiere auch zu halten.
Der Dünger geht wieder in den Acker,
so schliesst sich der Kreislauf.
Deshalb ist auch Fleischkonsum
auf eine Art sinnvoll.
Er muss ja nicht übertrieben sein.
Aber ich finde,
ein bewusster ist sinnvoll.
(Georg und Claudia
betreiben den Hof gemeinsam.)
(Auch wenn sie momentan mit den drei
Söhnen mehr im Haus angebunden ist.)
(Der Kleinste ist Ignaz, sein Bruder
Men geht in den Kindergarten.)
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Mona, ich würde Gummistiefel
anziehen. - Ja.
Hast du gegessen?
Sonst bist du mürrisch.
(Luzi, der mittlere Junge,
ist vierjährig.)
(Gemeinsam
gehen wir zu den Schweinen.)
* Ignaz spricht unverständlich. *
Heute weiss ich nicht.
* Sie sprechen leise miteinander. *
(Das alte Leben als Kunststudentin
sei weit weg, erzählt Claudia.)
(Sie vermisse nichts ausser dann und
wann die Möglichkeiten der Stadt.)
Luzi, wir rufen mal,
vielleicht kommen sie.
Komm!
* Lockrufe *
* Heulende Lockrufe *
Ist das der Indianerschweineruf?
Komm!
* Gurgelnde, heulende Laute *
* Ignaz wimmert. *
Kommt mal!
Oh, schau jetzt!
- Jetzt! Hui!
(Das Leben als Bäuerin sei ihr
von Beginn weg vertraut gewesen.)
Ich glaube,
ich habe das ein wenig in mir drin.
Ich habe früher oft meinen Vater
in die Ställe begleitet.
Der Geruch oder einfach das ...
Schon das Land. Tier und Land.
Oder auch die Ruhe.
Ich glaube auch die Ruhe.
(Die Ruhe, ein Zuhause, aber auch
viel Arbeit haben sie gefunden.)
(Pro Woche arbeiten Claudia
und Georg rund 70 Std.)
(Für sie ist das in Ordnung.)
(Das Leben auf dem Hof
sei konkret und handfest -
anders als in der Kunst.)
(Hier ergebe alles irgendwie Sinn.)
* Blöken *
Ja, ja, ja. Gut. Kommt!
Jetzt freuen sie sich.
- Ja, sie haben ein Gaudi.
(Die Kühe verbringen die Nacht
draussen auf der Weide.)
(Ich schlafe in der Kammer
über dem Stall.)
Ei, ei, ei!
- Ist das gut?
Für gute Träume.
- Ja, genau.
* Miauen *
Hey. Hey.
Du kommst auch hierher?
Du schläfst heute auch hier?
Vielen Dank.
- Tschüss. - Tschau.
Na, du. Komm! Springst du hier hoch?
* Mona macht Locklaute. *
Komm! Ja, gut.
Na, du.
Ich glaube, ich habe meinen Bett-
partner für diese Nacht gefunden.
* Schnurren *
Na, du.
Es ist schon krass.
Die einen Tiere
sind zum Kuscheln und Streicheln da.
Die anderen
hegt und pflegt man genau gleich,
aber irgendwann schlachtet man sie.
Das ist schon schräg, oder?
* Lockere Jazzmusik *
"Endlich gibt der Falter Ruhe
und sitzt brav auf seinem Schuhe."
"Globi knippst ihn mit Genuss,
doch es folgt sogleich Verdruss."
* Sanfte Jazzmusik *
* Muhen *
(Der Tag beginnt idyllisch
auf dem Bio-Hof im Domleschg -
auch für die Kühe.)
(Doch eine von ihnen ist heute
zum letzten Mal auf der Weide.)
(Georg und Claudia
leben von der Fleischproduktion
und machen vieles selbst.)
(Verkaufen sie ein Tier
einem Grossverteiler,
erhalten sie ca. 2'500 Fr.,
vermarkten sie das Fleisch selbst,
gibt es das Doppelte.)
(Ihre Produkte verkaufen sie
im Hofladen und via Internet.)
Du kannst hier zwei Reihen machen.
Jetzt müssen wir
noch den Preis anschreiben.
Ich fülle noch gleich
das Fleisch auf.
Diese kannst du
in die Kammer stellen, oder?
Kannst du mir helfen? Hackfleisch
und Haxen müssen wir auffüllen.
Haxen sind hier unten,
Hackfleisch da oben.
Können sich hier alle selbst
bedienen? - Ja, das klappt super.
Sicher? Stiehlt niemand etwas?
- Ich hoffe nicht.
Ähm ... Ja ...
Die Leute schreiben das auf
und bezahlen.
(Pro Jahr
verdienen sie etwa 50'000 Fr.)
(Trotz viel Arbeit
und Eigeninitiative -
ohne Direktzahlungen des Bundes
kämen sie nicht über die Runden.)
* Gackern *
Falls du vom Stuhl fällst.
(Am Mittagstisch sind auch ihr
Lehrling und ein Zivildienstler.)
(Landwirtschaft betreiben
ist Teamwork, alleine geht nichts.)
Danke.
- Du brauchst einen grösseren.
Luzi, willst du den Helm
nicht ausziehen?
Danke.
Dann brauchst du eine Spange?
- Ach ja?
Hier bist du wirklich
rund um die Uhr angebunden.
Hattest du zu Beginn
keine Mühe damit?
Nein, es war genau richtig so,
weil ich zuvor so frei war.
Das war gerade das Schöne,
so eingebunden zu sein.
Man wird auch gebraucht,
die Tiere brauchen einen.
Zuvor die Kunst war ...
Es ist so ...
Es wartet niemand auf einen.
Es hat so viel und ist ...
Es muss ja gut sein und alles. Oh!
Wie viel hast du da?
Aber weshalb hat euch
die Landwirtschaft so gepackt?
Ich habe noch ein Studium
an der Hochschule absolviert.
Agronomie?
- Ja.
Das Fachwissen ist schon spannend.
Es gibt schon vieles,
gerade im Bereich Pflanzenbau,
Biologie, das sehr spannend ist.
Ja. Aber dann bist du
eine Art "studierter" Bauer?
Ja, es war ein super Studium.
Aber halt gar nicht praxislastig,
es war sehr viel Theorie.
Wir kamen hierher
und hatten nicht viel Ahnung.
Nichts.
Und ... Ja ... Es ist erstaunlich.
Aber wir hatten viel Hilfe.
Die Nachbarn haben uns unterstützt,
wir konnten Maschinen ausleihen
und ihnen Fragen stellen -
wann wir was machen müssen,
wann wir z.B. mähen müssen.
Darüber waren wir sehr dankbar.
Wart ihr zu Beginn etwas naiv?
- Ja, sicher.
Wir sind einfach rein
ohne zu überlegen.
Für die Kinder ist es schon cool
auf dem Bauernhof. Oder, Luzi?
(Sie wollen
ihren eigenen Weg finden.)
(Sei es mit dem Anpflanzen
alter Getreidesorten
oder in der Beziehung
zu ihren Tieren.)
Komm, Maloja! Komm, komm!
* Muhen *
Kommt! Komm, komm, Grosse!
* Lockrufe *
Sissi kommt auch.
Komm, Gute, komm! Kommt!
Also, gehen wir unten durch,
damit sie uns nicht überrennen.
Maloja, komm, komm! Kommt! Komm!
(Die Tiere kommen bei ihnen zur Welt
und werden bei ihnen geschlachtet.)
Komm!
* Pfeifen *
So, tipptopp.
Wie ist es für dich, zu wissen,
dass sie zum letzten Mal
auf der Weide war?
Ja, es ist so ... Man beginnt schon,
etwas Distanz zu nehmen.
Also es ist ...
- Das machst du?
Indem man etwas Distanz nimmt,
schützt man sich selbst ein wenig.
Oder?
- Ja.
Du könntest es dir
auch einfacher machen.
Viele verkaufen an einen Händler.
Der holt fünf Tiere ab,
nimmt sie mit
und verkauft sie
z.B. an eine Metzgerei.
Dann hat man eine grosse Distanz
zu dem, was nachher kommt.
Man merkt, dass es Herdentiere sind.
Das ist ihr Instinkt.
Sie wollen um jeden Preis
in der Gruppe bleiben.
Ja.
- Das ist ihre Natur.
Das spürt man.
- Woran spürt man das?
Sie werden sehr nervös.
Wenn man die Kühe hier rauslässt
und eine zurückbleibt,
weil er den Weg verpasst hat ...
Was ist?
(Luzi) Kann ich ein paar geben?
- Nachher, ja.
... dann werden sie nervös,
suchen einen Ausweg und beginnen ...
... sie beginnen ...
... zu koten und urinieren.
Man spürt, dass sie gestresst sind.
Ja.
- Und ja ...
Denkst du,
du wirst heute Nacht gut schlafen?
Ich denke, sie ist eine ganz Feine
und ganz Ruhige.
Ich denke, es wird gut gehen.
Aber bei Tieren weiss man nie.
(In Schlachthöfen werden Rinder
im Minutentakt geschlachtet -
nach einer Anfahrt
von bis zu 8 Std.)
(Georg und Claudia
wollen es anders machen.)
(Und doch ist es noch immer
ein Töten.)
(Gibt es überhaupt
eine gute Schlachtung?)
(Diese Frage nehme ich mit
in eine unruhige Nacht.)
* Fliessende Jazzmusik *
* Vogelzwitschern *
Die Katze kommt auch schon.
* Miauen *
(Auf der einen Seite
die friedliche Stimmung,
auf der anderen Seite wird in 2 Std.
ein Leben beendet.)
(Zum Leben auf dem Bauernhof
gehören beide Seiten.)
Was ist das dort?
- Ich muss Administration machen.
Für jedes Tier
muss ich ein Formular ausfüllen.
Für jedes Tier, das von Hof zu Hof
oder vom Hof zur Metzgerei geht,
muss ein Formular ausgefüllt werden.
Dort steht drauf: Wer, wann,
welches Tier zu welchem Zweck.
Dann gibt es einen Stempel drauf
vom Tierarzt.
* Muhen *
(Bald ist es so weit.)
Du Kleine.
* Vogelzwitschern *
(Claudia geht weg,
bis die Schlachtung zu Ende ist.)
(Auch Georg ist nervös.)
(Wir warten auf den Metzger
und die Tierärztin.)
Wenn man warten muss, verstreicht
die Zeit sehr langsam, nicht?
* Mona stimmt leise zu. *
V.a. wäre ich eigentlich froh,
wenn das, worauf wir warten,
gar nicht eintreffen würde.
Das ist auch absurd.
Für mich ist es immer
ein angespannter Moment.
Von jetzt an bis es knallt
ist die Zeit, in der ich ...
... gewissermassen
am wenigsten Kontrolle habe.
Jetzt muss ich einfach darauf
setzen, dass alles so funktioniert,
wie wir es erarbeitet haben.
Und doch bin ich angespannt.
Ich hole jetzt mal Futter für die
Kälber und schaue, wann sie kommt.
Ja, ich muss schauen, wie ich es
mache. Ich muss es ausprobieren.
Ist gut. Ich bin einfach hier.
(Georg lockt Tschigulatta
mit Heu an den richtigen Ort.)
Jetzt kommen alle anderen.
Das ist meistens so.
Komm, Tschigulatta!
Komm!
Mal schauen, ob sie da hinten
bekommt, dann ist gut. Komm!
Nein, du nicht.
Komm, Tschigulatta, komm!
(Seit längerer Zeit
macht er das jeden Morgen so,
damit es für das Rind
möglichst normal ist.)
Kannst du hier, Chef?
So ist okay.
Mona, du kannst die Kälber da vorne
füttern, in Ordnung? - Ja.
(Es ist vorgeschrieben, dass das
Schlachttier beim Töten auf dem Hof
von den anderen Tieren
getrennt werden muss.)
Niki, hoi.
- Hoi. Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen, Georg.
- Guten Morgen, Tanja.
Guten Morgen.
- Mona, guten Morgen.
(Die Tierärztin Tanja Albertin
und Metzger Niki Bieler sind da -
jetzt geht alles schnell.)
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
* Rattern des Motors *
Hier ist das Sägemehl.
(Mein Job: das Sägemehl. Damit
kein Blut im Boden versickert.)
(Auch das ist eine Vorschrift.)
Warte kurz! Jetzt ist gut.
Dann sind wir so weit, in Ordnung?
Du kannst schiessen.
* Knall *
* Kettenrasseln *
(Das Zucken seien nur noch
die Nerven, sagte Georg.)
(Das Tier sei nicht mehr
bei Bewusstsein.)
(Trotzdem tut es weh, hinzuschauen.)
(Die anderen Rinder fressen weiter,
als wäre nichts geschehen.)
(Nach dem Bolzenschuss
bleiben 60 Sek.
für den Schnitt
in die Halsschlagader.)
Soll ich das Sägemehl erst
am Schluss verstreuen? - Wie bitte?
Oder soll ich jetzt schon streuen?
- Nein, warte noch.
Bis du siehst, dass das Blut
spritzt. - Ja, ist gut.
(Ich kann fast nicht hinschauen.)
(Und ich möchte das alles
lieber gar nicht sehen.)
(Und doch denke ich:
Wenn man Fleisch isst,
muss man auch für diesen Teil
der Geschichte bereit sein.)
Du kannst es grosszügig verteilen.
Da, wo das Blut ist.
Auch von der anderen Seite.
- Ja.
(Georg) Wir haben's in 3 Min.
Ist das jetzt ideal abgelaufen?
- Ja, es ist perfekt abgelaufen.
Auch die Zeiten, die man
einhalten muss, waren perfekt.
Im Moment.
- Ja.
Jetzt bleiben uns noch 45 Min.,
bis das Tier ausgenommen sein muss.
Es tut mir extrem leid für das Tier.
Andererseits hatte Georg recht
mit dem, was er sagte.
Sie hat bis zum Schluss gefressen,
das war ihr normales Leben.
Dann dauert es ...
... 10 Sek.
und das Leben ist zu Ende.
Mona, wir können gehen.
- Ja. Kommt das drüber?
Wir schliessen hier,
dann decken wir es ab.
Dann kannst du einsteigen.
Ich helfe dir. - Ja. Danke.
* Eindringliche Jazzmusik *
(Metzger Niki erwartet uns schon
im Schlachthof in Bonaduz.)
(Diese Art zu Schlachten ist
in den wenigsten Kantonen erlaubt.)
(Der Kanton Graubünden
ist ein Pionier.)
(Die Auflagen sind streng. Erst zwei
Bauern im Kanton schlachten so.)
(Die Tierärztin Tanja Albertin
ist dafür verantwortlich,
dass alles
vorschriftsgemäss abläuft.)
Ja.
- Ist das gut?
Mona, kannst du die Kiste bringen?
Wohin geht das? Wird das weggeworfen
oder weiterverwendet?
In der Regel nimmt es jemand.
Es ist verkehrt, damit man es
nachher darüberstülpen kann.
Weshalb gibt es erst so wenig Leute,
die Hofschlachtungen machen?
Erstens,
weil es erst neu aufgekommen ist.
Zum anderen
kann es gar nicht jeder machen.
Du siehst es zeitlich.
Wenn man zu weit weg
vom Schlachtbetrieb ist,
schafft man es nicht,
die Zeiten einzuhalten.
Deshalb kommt es für viele
gar nicht infrage. - Ja.
Aber wie siehst du das
als Tierärztin?
Diese Art des Schlachtens?
Für das Tier ist es natürlich
zweifellos optimal.
Das ist super für das Tier.
Das Tier stand hier, hat gefressen,
war ruhig.
Super.
- Ja.
Es geht sehr schnell.
Erst schaut man ... das Tier an,
weiss sogar, wie es heisst,
man krault und füttert es noch.
Dann hängt es plötzlich hier
und man sieht die einzelnen Stücke.
Das ist wirklich ...
... Fleisch.
Jetzt sind wir wirklich im Fleisch-
bereich, es wird zum Lebensmittel.
Ist das etwas Schlechtes,
dass wir so schnell umdenken?
Es war ein Tier, das wir mochten,
jetzt ist es nur noch Nahrung.
Müssen wir uns schuldig fühlen?
- Nein.
Findest du nicht?
Wenn man Veganer oder Vegetarier
ist, sieht man das sicher anders.
als wenn man Fleisch isst.
- Ja.
Vielleicht möchten das
auch viele Fleischesser nicht sehen.
Die meisten, würde ich behaupten.
Vielleicht.
- Ja.
Sicherlich möchten viele davon
nur das Schnitzel auf dem Teller.
Und den Rest blenden sie aus.
- Genau.
* Sägegeräusch *
(Auf dem Hof schlachten,
wie es Georg macht,
wird in der Schweiz
die Ausnahme bleiben.)
(Aufwand und Kosten seien zu gross,
auch der Schweizer Fleischkonsum
sei zu hoch, sagt Tanja.)
(Sie prüft das Fleisch,
bevor es freigegeben wird.)
Ist es gut?
- Ja, das ist gut.
Hat sie da wirklich noch Gras drin?
- (Lachend) Ja.
Weil sie bis zum Schluss gefressen
hat. - Bis zur letzten Sekunde.
Ja.
Darf ich dich fragen ... Wie ...
Ist es für dich ein Unterschied, ob
du ein Tier auf dem Hof schlachtest,
oder in einem Schlachthaus?
Hier schlachte ich auch lebendige
Tiere. Aber das andere ist ...
Wie soll ich sagen ...
Für mich mehr Aufwand.
Du hast gesehen, es ist einfach.
Sie merken das nicht. - Ja.
Hier müssen sie hineinlaufen,
da merken sie etwas.
Aber meistens führt sie der Bauer
hinein, dann ist das kein Problem.
Spürst du, wie es einem Tier geht,
wenn du es schlachtest?
Das sieht man schon.
Wenn es nass ist, wenn es
im Lastwagen oder Anhänger kommt ...
Wenn das Fell nass ist,
braucht man sie nicht zu schlachten.
Warum?
- Dann sind sie nervös.
Das Adrenalin ist so weit oben,
dass das nichts bringt.
Es wäre schlechte Qualität.
- Ach so. Okay.
Bei ihnen hier merkt man nichts.
Sie sind auch trocken im Fell.
Ja.
- Oder.
Wenn einer mit dem Anhänger
schnell gefahren ist,
sieht man es dem Tier an.
- Ja.
(Das Ganze nimmt mich ziemlich mit.)
(Dabei ist es eine Realität,
die sich täglich
in der Schweiz abspielt.)
(Nur erfahren wir
meistens nichts davon.)
* Eindringlich
pulsierende Jazzmusik *
(Auf dem Hof in Paspels
ist wieder der Alltag eingekehrt.)
* Glockenbimmeln *
(Ich helfe Claudia und Georg,
die Glocken anzupassen
für den Alpaufzug.)
Also. Hier unten steht jeweils
ein Name, siehst du?
Das ist diese hier.
Wie eng muss es sein?
Muss ein Finger dazwischen passen?
Ja, genau eine Hand.
Weshalb zieht man ihnen
überhaupt Glocken an?
So hört der Hirt,
wenn eine woanders ist.
Also für den Alpaufzug.
- Das ist wirklich wichtig.
Für die Kleinen eigentlich auch,
aber die wachsen noch.
Es würde zu eng.
Deshalb tragen sie keine.
Sie ging letztes Jahr ohne Glocke
auf die Alp.
Ja.
- Da war es so.
Dann trägt sie dieses Jahr
zum ersten Mal eine. - Ja.
Wie ist die Zeit für euch,
wenn die Tiere auf der Alp sind?
Es ist viel ruhiger.
- Aber auch ... fast zu ruhig, oder?
Ja.
- Es lebt nicht mehr.
Am Tag danach ist Totenstille.
- Totenstille.
Aber es ist gut. Im Sommer
hat man Zeit für andere Dinge.
Man kann eine Woche wegfahren.
Für sie ist es auch schön.
Hier wird es ja sehr heiss.
Oben ist es sehr kühl.
Ich glaube, für sie
ist es eine schöne Zeit. - Ja.
Und für euch ist es ruhig.
Ja, etwas ruhiger.
Wie viele Wochen Ferien
hattet ihr in diesen fünf Jahren?
Ähm ... eine, oder?
- Ich glaube zwei.
Nein, jetzt kommt die zweite.
Ach, nein. Zwei. Stimmt.
Jetzt kommt die dritte.
* Georg stöhnt angestrengt. *
Geht es?
* Mona stöhnt angestrengt. *
Ja, du.
Jetzt seid ihr fünf Jahre hier.
Wie lange habt ihr vor,
hier Landwirtschaft zu betreiben?
Der Pachtvertrag
läuft ja irgendwann aus.
Noch 25 Jahre. - Bis zum Schluss.
Bis 65 wäre schon schön.
Sicher?
- Ja.
Solange wir können.
- Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wir sehen keinen Grund, wegzugehen.
Wenn es geht, möchten wir bleiben.
Es bleibt spannend.
Ich hätte mir
auch vorstellen können,
dass ihr das als Phase im Leben seht
und es dann weitergeht.
Aber ihr habt hier das Leben
gefunden, das ihr gesucht habt.
Wenn es nur eine Phase wäre,
hätten wir das schon lange gespürt.
In diesen fünf Jahren.
- Ja.
Wir sind schon angekommen.
Also du kommst ...
Für die Kinder ist es eine Heimat.
Sie sind hier aufgewachsen.
Wir fühlen uns auch langsam
zu Hause. Man schlägt Wurzeln.
Vielen Dank.
- Danke dir.
Danke, dass ich bei euch
vorbeischauen durfte.
Jetzt können wir sie herauslassen.
- (Beide) Lassen wir sie heraus.
* Pulsierende Musik,
lautes Glockenbimmeln *
Oh, schau mal!
(Die Kühe gehen auf die Weide
und ich zurück in meine Welt.)
* Mona lacht. *
(Nach diesen drei Tagen
werde ich nicht mehr gleich
vor der Fleischtheke stehen.)
* Eindringliche Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2019